hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so in this video i want to
talk about
breakouts i want to show you guys how to
identify a breakout
and how to trade it also i want to show
you guys how to avoid
fake breakouts which are bull traps or
bear traps
let's get into it
[Music]
my first example i want to show you guys
how to identify a breakout so i'm going
to take the eur usd
chart i did some technical analysis on
this one it was i think my third or
fourth video of this channel
uh and i was basically saying that i'm
bullish
guys on the euro dollar uh above 118
and that i see the euro dollar trading
around 130 135 maybe
at the end of next year the reason
behind that is actually
a breakout so i'm going to show you guys
how i saw it
and how i would trade it so when you
look at a
all right so i'm gonna get rid of this
first but
you need to identify a trend you need to
find
some obvious resistance or support
levels
so here you can see that the trend is
bearish right and you can see that here
you have
some kind of a resistance so you just
draw it
okay so i'm trying to make it connect as
best as i can the highs that i see here
so this one is not perfect but at least
we are almost touching this one we're
touching this one
we're touching this one here and here we
have our
breakout so let's check this
in the shoulder time frame and let's see
what happens
all right so this is
a breakout so basically we have a
support level that is
uh broken and we have the confirmation
so for example here on daily timeframe
my confirmation would be given by um
given the length of the move this is
more a weekly move
so it would be given by a second candle
that is trading above
so first one here this is not the
breakout yet and second
then it is a breakout okay i'm going to
show you guys
why you should not buy the breakout what
can happen how
bad it can go if you do this but first a
breakout
occurs once you have two candles in the
time frame you are watching
that are trading above it so this is a
nice
one and then once you have identified it
you go
to the to a shorter time frame and you
try to enter your trade
so you need to find some support levels
that are close to the level you want to
buy
so for example the breakout level is a
nice level to to buy for example
all right very basic here okay
uh so let's put this one in green
so this is a breakout level so
everything that is touching this
would act as support all right so that's
why here
is it came back and here it came back
another one is just you keep
the resistance level then you had and
once the resistance is broken guys a
resistance
become support all right uh um i told
you this before
this is very important in technical
analysis and this is what we use to
trade breakouts as well
so here you can see this was my
resistance line
all right and here look it got just
touched a little bit
then second time all right so you have
two days actually two days you could buy
here this level
and just put a sty stop loss here you
see so this kind of trade is quite safe
and it allows you to enter your trade
after the breakout has been confirmed
another way to do this
you can just use some moving averages so
here for example the 20 is definitely uh
too close to the price action
but you could have used the 50. so you
could have both here
okay then maybe you would have put the
stop loss here which is not good so you
can see here for example it wouldn't be
nice to use the 50 all right because the
50
is far from the other support levels
that i have using other techniques
so i have one here one here so i would
be a buyer close to here so if i have a
moving average coming here it's even
better but if i don't i won't buy here
all right another technique you can use
is just
use the fibs guys fib retracements so
you just identify the last wave
before you break out so here the last
wave is this one all right
so i take from here to here
and i just buy as usual i did 38.2
and the 50 and i stopped at the 78
so you buy here 116.8 so you have you
know
one more level coming here you buy more
at
1 15 8 and
um and you stop your position
around uh just below the 61.8 right
because this is a level we often go to
uh we rarely go
below if we are uh like if the market is
bullish it usually doesn't come back
here it all depends on like which wave
it is
i'm not gonna go through this here but
in this situation
when the market is very bullish because
we broke a
major resistance level on the weekly
time frame then
usually the good levels to buy 38.2 and
50. so here
here you stop here so basically here i
have three indicators telling me that
this is the level to buy and guys
it worked in this situation now what i
want to show you guys is
what you should not do alright so i'm
gonna go on the s
p 500 so this is the futures market so
for those who watch my other videos i
was basically telling you guys that i
see here
uh some weakness because i see a wedge
pattern that is here
all right so which pattern is a pattern
that has a support level and a
resistance level that i converging to
the same point
so it has to end at some point
this kind of which pattern cannot be
cannot last forever that's what i was
saying in my other
s p 500 analysis so here
a breakout would be can be on both sides
it can be on the downside
or on the upside as you can see here
guys we had what we call a fake breakout
so don't fall into this trap
all right you need to wait as i said
to have two candles uh that are in the
time frame you're watching so here you
can watch four hours you can watch you
know
uh one hour it doesn't really matter but
what you can see
for example the four hours is that we
have here a breakout
okay so here if you sell here guys
i mean first you need to be very quick
to be here because this move was very
sharp
so basically here you won't be you won't
have time to sell here so maybe you
would sell
here or here and guys how would you feel
the next hour when the market just is
coming back with a lot of power back
like to the wedge pattern it just had
break breakout
off you would feel really bad and you
would take a bad decision that's for
sure
when things start to you know to
be bad for your trade it's usually the
time you take the decisions
you know are not good but you still take
them for example here just
stay in the trade and hope this is uh
this is just like you know for a while
and that
eventually we had this breakout but guys
you didn't have it
because you have only one candle here
that goes here second
hour look how strong this was all right
it didn't come back to the wedge pattern
but just below
and then it came back all right if you
look at the four hours time frame
which i think is better here because
you know it's just visual i'm used to
this kind of stuff and i can tell you
that here
basically if your candles look you can't
really see them
it means you are not using the right
time frame for your chart here i can see
each candle very properly so i know that
the four out
four hours time frame fits very well the
switch pattern i'm checking so it's even
a better signal
so once you have two candles in a row
that are below it with the closing price
of the second candle that is below
this is the confirmation and then you
enter your trade using the techniques i
gave you so for example you can enter
your trade here
because this support level became
resistance or you can use fibs
so you would take this candle here here
and you sell 38.50 and you stop your
position here so here you would have
been stopped because this is a fake
breakout all right so this is the kind
of traps guys
you should not fall in this is a bear
trap all right
be very careful wait for the
confirmation and yeah otherwise
moving averages all right so very
quickly i show you again guys in this
example here
so here this is a very nice breakout
because as we can see on the longer time
frame
we broke above this level and then we
just
do so the resistance becomes becomes
support so we can buy here by here
here the level of the breakout is good
to buy and we can use fib on the last
wave and by the 32.2 and 50
and stop at six just below 61.8 so here
you would stop here
okay you buy here you buy here you you
can even buy more here
and you stop everything here all right
and then you try to
find the next resistance level and this
is the level you are going to
take your profits so it's here for the
euro dollar it's
1 25 5. okay guys that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video i hope you
understand now what is the difference
between
a breakout where you have the
confirmation and a force a fake breakout
that you should not trade and the
different techniques you can use to get
back in the trade once you have the
breakout
so i repeat the resistance becomes
support or the support
becomes resistance so this is the first
thing you can use
moving averages of fibs all right you
buy the 38.2
50 uh you can even buy the 61.8 and you
stop
everything just below all right guys
that's it for me
stay close to shaw i see you guys